[Music]  meagan Markel and boyfriend Prince Harry  attended the Invictus games you don't  know half of it the 36 year old suit  star was spotted during her royal man's  third annual event for wounded veterans  in Toronto Canada on Saturday marking  their first public appearance together  though Megan sat a few rows back from  the 33 year old Prince she looked happy  as ever  smiling and clapping during the opening  ceremonies while looking fabulous and a  velvet burgundy dress and matching  leather jacket draped across her  shoulders giving us major fall vibes  meanwhile Prince Harry look dapper  donning a blue suit with a white  button-down shirt and black tie while  sitting alongside First Lady Melania  Trump who was leading the USA team  delegation to the games earlier this  month Megan broke her silence about her  romance with the Prince telling Vanity  Fair quote were two people who are  really happy and in love  [Music]  you